Speaker 1: You've been listening to my podcast for
a while, if you've been watching the show for a
while, you know that on this show I try to, but I
try to do a lot of different things. But for our
purposes today, I always want to be clear when
I tell you that we know something to be true.
That we suspect something to be true based on some
evidence and data, or that we're just guessing and
speculating, we can now move from mere speculation
to weaken suspect based on early data that
the Omicron variant or the omni crime, as some
call it, it's actually Omicron that the Omicron
variant, which led to market turmoil over the last
couple of weeks. Panic everywhere might actually
be less severe in terms of its rate at which it
causes severe disease than the Delta variant. That
is potentially a very welcome change to this
trajectory of the COVID pandemic. Now I'm going to
tell you what. Is making us suspect that and I'm
going to be clear about the fact that we are still
missing some of the data that we need. We are now
close to two weeks since the big kind of coming
out party of Omicron, which took control of the
corporate news cycle starting on and right after
Thanksgiving lasted several days and now sort of
in subsequent forms has lasted nearly two weeks.
Dr. Anthony Fauci, who heads up the NIH lead
infectious disease doctor in the United States,
is now calling the early signs encouraging
about Omicron. Without question,
this variant appears to be as or up to
significantly more contagious than Delta.
That's sort of like one side of the equation. It's
spreading rapidly, it's spreading very rapidly
and hospitalizations are going up. But the data
we have so far is that the hospitalizations
are going up because of Delta Delta driving
hospitalizations. It does not appear at this time
that Omicron is actually leading to significant
hospitalization at all. It is spreading quickly.
It may ultimately outcompete Delta in terms of
infections, but for right now. And Dr. Fauci
concurs. It is encouraging that while it appears
to be more contagious, it seems to be less severe
now. The dream scenario would be that Omicron,
in exchange for being wildly contagious,
is more of a cold than a serious virus, with
a death rate close to one percent. As COVID
has been throughout this pandemic, that means it
will spread. But fewer people comparatively will
end up in the hospital and die. That's the hope
and we don't yet know. Dr. Fauci was on CNN this
weekend where he said quote Thus far, it does not
look like there a great degree of severity to it.
But we have really got to be careful before we
make any determinations that it is less severe
or it really doesn't cause any severe illness.
So this is really the key thing to understand
if you look at something for 15 seconds and then
make a conclusion. You are almost certainly not
operating even with the full data that we have
and the full data that we have is still not as
full as it ultimately needs to be. If you just
look and you see, while cases are spiking,
hospitalizations are up, Omicron must be a
disaster. But remember, we expected to some degree
that cases and hospitalizations were going
to spike during the winter. The question is,
is the news about Omicron from nearly two weeks
ago? The reason for the spiking hospitalizations
and it appears for now that the answer is no. It
is delta driving hospitalizations in the north
of the U.S., not Omicron. So still understand
that if Omicron is as contagious as it might be,
it will infect a lot more people. So even if the
hospitalization rate is lower, you might still
end up with more people hospitalized. In terms of
raw numbers, some of them will end up in the ICU.
Some of them will die. Just imagine,
I mean, you know, this is made up, but
imagine that we determined Omicron is three times
as contagious but half as deadly. That still means
more people are going to end up in the hospital,
a lower percentage of those that get the virus,
but more people will end up in the hospital.
Lastly, we also have to remember that the
prevailing narratives about these variants at the
start are often untrue. And that's why I've been
going out of my way. I mean, nearly two weeks
now that I've been saying right now, all we
have is anecdotes. Now all we have is preliminary
data. That's where we are right now with Delta.
Initially, it was all sort of muted. It was
more neutral. It was starting to spread in
other countries and hospitalizing a lot of people.
But there was not really the panic media coverage.
And then a huge spike with tons of deaths hit
the United States and basically everywhere. And
then the media coverage changed with Omicron. The
coverage started with complete and total panic.
Now it seems it may be more mild still could end
up going some other way. The point is, two weeks
in, we don't know. And for now, I wouldn't be
taking any chances on the assumption that it's
more mild in a few weeks. We will know for sure
now over time. This is how viruses stop being
a pandemic. We learned this in our interview
with Columbia University's virologist Vincent
Racaniello. In general, viral evolution tends
to be more contagious and less severe, but it
can still be deadly for years and years and years
now from a kind of. Sociological standpoint, the
level of fatigue with this is obviously very, very
high. A lot of people just feeling I'm throwing in
the towel. It's time to move on. I'm not going to
pay attention any more. I'm going to do whatever.
That's not where I am right now, as I've said
in bits and pieces. I got my third shot. Early
data is that that third shot is very effective
at preventing you from getting sick at all,
much more than just the two doses. We're still
waiting on more data there, but that's hopeful.
Any place that says masks recommended, I'm wearing
a mask. I'm not going to movie theaters. I'm not
going to concerts. I'm not going to sporting
events and these types of large events.
I am going to restaurants indoors. If the tables
aren't very close together, I care less about,
do I have to wear a mask up to the counter to
order? I care more about Am I going to sit for
an hour really, really close to another table? I'm
not going to those. I'm not going to bars where
people are hanging out for hours. I am, of course,
flying, but with a mask that's legally required
and I'm seeing friends who who I know are
vaccinated and whose daily risk level is
acceptable to me. They either work from home or
have a low level of risk indoors. I am doing that.
It is true. You know, the right's talking points
are always they grapple with a kernel of truth
and go too far. Isolation has consequences, but
for a long time for me, the risk balance told me,
I'm going to stick with the isolation, with
what we now know and having three doses. I'm
more comfortable trading some risk for decreased
isolation and more socialization. Everybody has to
run this calculation for themselves, but the key
is run it with actual accurate information, which
we are still gathering when it
comes to the Omicron variant